i'll just what you just won a grammy
love being nominated
i just i just want a grammy tiffany
haddish is officially
a grammy winner y'all serious i'm
serious
there's no lie this is for real i really
would
and the grammy goes to
black mitzvah tiffany haddish the
comedian took to social media sunday
night to share her candid reaction to
winning grammy gold
there's tiffany crying on the set of her
cbs show
kids say the darndest things right after
learning she won the award
you've been nominated a couple times
yeah i've been nominated a couple of
times for some things
but i just and i love i'll just what
you just want a grammy love being
nominated i just i just want a grammy
no i just are you are you serious i'm
not lying
i'm telling you the truth the moment was
captured while cameras were rolling on
tiffany's show
as a producer behind the scenes fed her
lines
including the one about her new grammy
achievement
did y'all see this thing in my ear y'all
see this in my ear
tell them all you just want to grab me
tiffany won the 2021 grammy award for
best comedy album for her netflix
special black mitzvah
where she beat out jerry seinfeld patton
oswalt
bill burr and jim gaffigan as tiffany
broke down in tears
she shared why this win means so much to
her
you know a black woman has a hasn't won
in that category since 1986
yeah black woman hasn't won for best
comedy album since whoopi goldberg
can i tell you why i'm crying why it's a
lot of bumpy roads that you cross
right you just have to believe in
yourself as much as you can
and it gives all odds you just say you
know what i'm gonna just put my best
foot forward and i'm gonna give
give the world the best that i got right
anything is possible e.t has spoken with
tiffany many times
throughout her career including in 2019
at the premiere of black mitzvah
when she hilariously opened up about her
plans for the future
my list of to do's and grown womanhood
is a well you know every grown woman got
to have a man
so i'm looking for one of those also i'm
looking to buy
more property create opportunities for
others
and you know build my own studio lucille
ballet you know